[smooth jazz music]
♪ ♪
[in Jamaican accents]
- SUE!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
HOW ARE YOU DOING, GIRL?
- OH, YOU KNOW, I WAS ON
MY WAY HOME AND WAS IN THE AREA.
I JUST WANTED TO COME
SAY "HELLO."
THAT'S IT.
THAT IS ALL.
HAVE A NICE NIGHT.
- SUE, WHERE YOU GOING, GIRL?
YOU CAN'T LEAVE
WITHOUT COMING INSIDE.
- OH, NO, I WOULDN'T WANT
TO BE AN INTRUSION.
I JUST WANTED TO SAY
"HELLO."
GOOD-BYE.
- OKAY, NOW, SUE.
THERE IS A SEAT
IN THIS HOUSE
WITH YOUR NAME ON IT, GIRL.
- NO, NO, NO,
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
I CAN'T.
I DIDN'T HAVE MONEY
FOR THE BUS.
I'M A MESS
FROM THE 50-MILE WALK.
- NOW, WHY MUST YOU BE
SO DIFFICULT, GIRL?
- YOU'RE RIGHT.
I AM BEING DIFFICULT,
AREN'T I?
YOUR LIFE IS BETTER
WITHOUT ME COMING IN,
TRUST ME, SO THERE I GO.
- OKAY, GIRL, LISTEN,
EVERYTHING IS IRIE, MAN.
WE'RE GOOD FRIENDS,
ALL RIGHT?
- YES, OF COURSE.
- AND YOU KNOW
YOU CAN SMELL IT, GIRL.
YOU KNOW YOU SMELL IT, GIRL.
- WHAT'S THAT SMELL?
- YOU KNOW YOU'RE SMELLING
THE FRIED DUMPLINGS,
THE ACKEE,
AND THE SALTFISH, GIRL.
- OH.
- NOW, WHAT'S COME OVER YOU?
- I SHOULD HAVE CALLED.
I SHOULD HAVE CALLED.
- THAT'S IT, SUE!
I'M FORMALLY INVITING YOU
INTO MY HOME.
NOW COME INSIDE.
- [hisses]
[dramatic music]
[smooth jazz music]
[slurping, flesh ripping]
[haunting western music]